يبدو واضحا
انستاني الان يعني اتخذ الخطه الذي تسمح
له باستخدام الطيران
لتحجيم وضربي مقار الدعم السريع يعني الان
اصبحت هي قوات كما قال انهم متمرده ويريد
ان يقطع اي ميلاد لقواته للقوات وان يسيطر
من خلال استخدام سلاح الطيران في ظل
النيران المشتعل التي
والدتي التي يعني وقعت في المطار الخصوم
ويعني راينا كيف ان هناك اشتعال بعد
الطائرتين في في مدرج الخرطوم مما يعني ان
الان المرافق الاشتراكيه تواجه خطر تمام
في سمعنا ان هناك الان عدد كبير من
المسافرين هم الان حديث الصلاه بل هناك
مواطنين الان ذهبوا للاختباء يعني في
برومات العمارات وال
طابق المباني العاليه فهذا يعني كله يشير
الى الحاله التي يعيش فيها المواطن
السوداني الان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات